[Music]
last weekend lucky fans of Shazam were
treated to advanced screenings of the
movie that introduced the character in a
fantastic way whilst also teasing what's
to come in the future our team were
lucky enough to catch one of these
previews of the movie and were happy to
say that the film is really enjoyable
and the two and credit scenes have a lot
to unpack from them throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about those scenes
and what they mean for the future of the
franchise this is full spoilers ahead so
if you don't want to know anything about
the movie and then I highly recommend
that you turn off now with that out the
way thanks for checking out the video
I'm your host definition and welcome to
the channel where I explain it so you
don't have to okay so the first post
credit scene picks up right after the
ending of the film with the defeated dr.
sivana locked in a prison cell the
character is painting symbols of the
seven deadly sins on the wall before
he's interrupted by none other than mr.
mind those who are familiar with Shazam
will know that the character possesses
telepathy and also the ability to spin
at near indestructible silk at speeds
faster than the human eye can register
the character is near identical to his
comic book counterpart and it's great
that DC are leaning heavily into the
source material with this one mind is
part of the monster Society of evil and
this is sort of a lower tier Legion of
Doom made up of members like dummy mr.
hoo and crocodile man personally I've
always viewed these as kind of joke
characters and they're not really
headline acts for DC graphic novels so
it seems strange that Warner Brothers
have decided that they should be the
next vote obviously though they bring a
wealth of dynamics to the proceedings so
it seems like next time the creators are
aiming for a more family-friendly group
of villains for the titular hero to face
off against and now on to the second
post credits scene so a couple of months
ago I dropped a first screening reaction
video from a member of the Warner
Brothers team that got in touch with me
after seeing an assembly caught up with
originally he said that there was a head
down shove Superman but at that time it
was just a stand-in and that Warner
Brothers were still negotiating
contracts with Henry Cavill who plays
the character unfortunately it doesn't
look like the details were ironed out as
the second post-credit scene is just a
gag that was even shown in trailers the
scene shows Shazam attempting to speak
to his fish his Freddie Freeman watches
this is of course a little nudge and
acknowledgement of Aquaman but it's
bound to disappoint those who are
expecting a big cameo from one of DC's
a-listers overall we're a bit unsure
what to make of both of these and it
seems to confirm that DC are heading
down a joker ooh that's more in line
with Marvel that's not to say the movies
bad though and we did have a lot of fun
with it so make sure you keep your eye
out for a full spoiler talk breakdown
which will be online later in the week
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on both the scenes and if you'll be
sticking around for them when the film
hits theaters in April covered below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then make sure you check out my
full breakdown of last week's big movie
us which would be linked at the end this
is a channel for people who are super
into superheroes so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]